ahora
[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález comenzó en
bruselas la sede de la unión europea la
cumbre de jefes de estado y de gobierno
de la unión europea y la unión africana
serán dos días de encuentro de alto
nivel en el que se busca refundar la
relación que existe entre las dos partes
la propuesta europea es hacer énfasis en
tres pilares básicos para el
relanzamiento de las relaciones que
tengan como soporte la prosperidad la
seguridad y la movilidad
desde el 2007 existe un plan de
estrategia conjunta entre la unión
europea y la unión africana que ha
estrechado los lazos entre las partes la
unión europea tiene 27 países miembros
sucede como lo decíamos está en bruselas
la capital de bélgica mientras que la
unión africana está compuesta por 55
países la sede principal es la ciudad de
addis abeba la capital de etiopía
como están regidas las relaciones entre
estos dos bloques el acuerdo de cotonú
es el marco general de estas alianzas
hay estrategias regionales impulsadas
desde el consejo europeo que han
adoptado por ejemplo una estrategia para
el cuerno de áfrica otra para el golfo
de guinea en áfrica occidental y otra
para la región del sahel solo por citar
algunas
hay diálogo también formal en diferentes
niveles asimismo hay reuniones entre las
diferentes comisiones pactadas y las
cumbres de jefes de estado y de gobierno
cada tres años como la que estamos
presenciando en este momento en bruselas
en bélgica
precisamente desde bruselas esther
herrera conductora del programa europa
hoy y también corresponsal de france 24
allí en la unión europea' nos da más
detalles del inicio de esta cumbre
escuchemos
europa espera volver a seducir a áfrica
tras años en que han sido unas
relaciones bastante complicadas entre
ambas regiones no sólo por cuestiones
históricas desde el continente africano
se tiene un poco la sensación que se les
ha tratado en los últimos años con
cierto desdén e incluso tampoco se han
sentido suficientemente apoyados la
pandemia tampoco ha ayudado mientras más
del 70% de los europeos está
completamente vacunado tan sólo el 11
por ciento del continente africano está
inmunizado porque no sólo se trata de la
lentitud con la que se están donando las
vacunas también por el rechazo de la
unión europea levantar las patentes tal
y como piden países como sudáfrica
además de este mismo país también ha
lamentado cual que cuando han surgido
variantes de preocupación como en el
caso de omikron europa rápidamente ha
cerrado sus fronteras sin embargo la
unión europea espera que con esta cumbre
ue-áfrica realmente se revitalicen estas
relaciones por ejemplo contando con el
continente para movilizar 150 mil
millones de euros se trata de la mitad
el capital que se espera movilizar en el
portal global una iniciativa de
infraestructuras y de inversiones que
propuso la comisión europea el pasado
septiembre y que sobre todo lo que
intenta es también hacer frente a la
ruta de la seda china la pregunta es que
se hacen algunos analistas si esto es
suficiente o si llega demasiado tarde
porque no se trata sólo de contrarrestar
la influencia de china también la de
rusia que está presente con el grupo de
mercenarios como el de wagner muy
presente en la región del sahel aún así
la unión europea espera que con esta
cumbre realmente haya verdaderos avances
y sea un punto y aparte
fortalecer una relación histórica que
también rodea muchos reclamos y dolor de
parte y parte
pero desde europa están decididos a
recuperar esa relación preferencial que
hubo en el pasado y que hoy como nos
decías esther desde bruselas ha sido
aprovechada por china al menos en
términos comerciales el país asiático es
el principal socio comercial de áfrica a
través de una enorme inversión en
infraestructura que implica una gran
deuda por parte de numerosos países
africanos pero que no ha terminado con
problemas de base como por ejemplo la
pobreza y la violencia que se presenta
en diferentes países africanos pues para
analizar este tema están con nosotros
sanz y la dan él es camerún es analista
de relaciones internacionales está en la
ciudad de madrid en españa y desde la
ciudad de cardiff en galés en el reino
unido se une a esta conversación david
solera analista internacional
especialista en asuntos africanos y
fundadores del medio digital áfrica
mundo ustedes nuestros televidentes
también pueden participar en este debate
con sus comentarios y sus preguntas lo
pueden hacer a través de las redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook
también en instagram en twitter estamos
como france24
santi logo que es 50 personal nuestra
etiqueta numeral el debate efe 24 para
que dejen todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas comienzo entonces con sunny en
la ciudad de madrid de la capital
española
para analizar este tema esta cumbre
entre la unión europea y la unión
africana sanz y gracias por estar con
nosotros en el programa y el punto de
partida de este encuentro es relanzar
esas relaciones entre la unión europea y
la unión africana porque relanzarlas en
este momento que se ha venido
desgastando deteriorando entre los dos
bloques que haya una necesidad de
reforzar los lazos
muchas gracias por la invitación hay que
reconocer que cuando se habla de
relanzar es decir que desde el principio
ha habido como un fallo o europa en este
caso pues se está dando cuenta de que se
está se había equivocado en su relación
que llevaba con el continente africano
es una relación histórica en la que se
ha basado durante mucho tiempo desde el
paternalismo y en este caso en el que
nunca se había tenido en cuenta la
agenda de los países africanos y ahora
yo diría incluso que esto está llegando
tarde porque esto es como una ofensiva
porque cuando leemos o cuando vemos todo
lo que se dice desde la unión europea
para relanzar este acuerdo para relanzar
esta esta unión digamos o esta relación
con el continente africano están
hablando desde términos como
contrarrestar el avance de china o
contrarrestar el avance de rusia en el
continente africano
ahí es donde también nos damos cuenta de
que
en ese sentido también como que se están
equivocando del sentido no en la ciudad
de cardiff david su opinión porque
relanzar este acuerdo entre la unión
europea y la unión africana que ha
fallado que ha faltado que toca
modificar en esos acuerdos
bueno muchas gracias por tenerme estoy
de acuerdo con sam y yo creo que de
alguna manera la unió europea
especialmente desde la pandemia que ha
llevado muchos años pero especialmente
desde la pandemia de alguna manera la
relación es tan deteriorado en materia
sanitaria normalmente establecer no
aceptar la liberalización de las
patentes y luego últimamente sobre todo
en la zona el el no conseguir avances en
materia de seguridad te ha llevado
incluso embajador francés en mali a ser
expulsado del país
europa lo que quiera de alguna manera es
borrón y cuenta nueva y empezar de cero
pero eso es eso es muy difícil que hay
unas relaciones muy históricas
de además muy diferente nivel en europa
está encima y así está sentado debajo y
para poder hacerlo de verdad tiene que
más que proponer esta nueva alianza
escuchar por un lado a los países
africanos ya la unión africana lo que
ellos quiero proponer y apoyando en ello
david continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa si tanto algunas
palabras de josep borrel el alto
representante de la unión europea para
los asuntos exteriores y para la
política de seguridad el en una columna
que ha publicado en el diario el país
titula europa debe ser el socio
preferente de áfrica porque esta
necesidad de europa de ser el socio
preferente de este continente del
continente africano y áfrica está
también en sintonía de querer tener a
europa como su socio preferente dadas
las condiciones que se están dando ahora
como lo ve usted
bueno europa de alguna manera es como si
se siente como que está perdiendo a ese
socio preferencial que ha tenido durante
tiempo pero como dices a mí llega un
poco tarde y de chinas y es el socio
comercial número uno desde 2009 no es
nuevo desde ahora lleva ya más de una
década en la que no le ha importado
mucho y ahora últimamente como sí que
tiene más resonancia por decirlo así e
intentar recuperar por distintas y
socios que ha tenido siempre de alguna
manera una conexión histórica vinculada
pero desde áfrica se ha recibido esta
nueva propuesta de el pacto global el
club world gateway más bien con
escepticismo están un poco cansados de
promesas por parte de europa además de
que ese dinero es de alguna manera un
empaquetado con dinero ya prometido de
antes en otras partidas presupuestarias
importante es una manera de ponerle un
nombre bonito tipo de la ruta de la seda
china para intentar
político global
ahora veamos la perspectiva africana
sanz y europa áfrica mejor está en esa
sintonía de querer tener volver a europa
su socio preferente dados los hechos de
los últimos años que ponen a china como
su socio comercial principal a todo
nivel y que les permite tener acceso a
préstamos financieros con muchas
facilidades que tal vez el sistema
financiero europeo no es tan amable
digámoslo así con los estados africanos
lo que se observa desde el continente
africano no solo dentro de la sociedad
civil sino también dentro de los propios
mandatarios es un escepticismo como lo
decía en avigase hace un rato
un escepticismo debido a las grandes
promesas que se han ido haciendo a lo
largo de la historia y yo creo que para
esta relación entre áfrica y europa lo
mejor que le ha podido pasar a áfrica es
tener esa opción de poder tener varios
socios en este caso para poder elegir y
para poder poner encima de la mesa
también su propia agenda porque no hay
que olvidar que en esta relación que ha
tenido áfrica con europa nunca se ha
tenido en cuenta la agenda del
continente africano es decir en materia
de desarrollo incluso en materia de
transformación verde en materia de
emigración o incluso en materia de paz y
seguridad no hay que olvidar que cuando
hubo los bombardeos en el 2011
de la otan en libia fue en contra
totalmente de la unión africana y es
algo que durante mucho tiempo la unión
africana reprocha en este caso
a europa en su relación
incluso en los acuerdos comerciales
hay muchos reproches que siguen ahí y el
escepticismo y el escepticismo está ahí
en esta relación y también nos damos
cuenta de que desde la unión europea-
desoyen las voces que se levantan dentro
del continente africano y que piden que
las relaciones se hagan en pie de
igualdad y de que salga un poco en esa
relación de asimetría que ha
caracterizado la relación entre áfrica y
europa sanz y continuó con usted usted
habla de escepticismo y de una falta de
entender esa agenda africana pero vuelvo
y cito a josep borrel al alto
representante
que también en esta columna mencionaba
que hay que abordar a áfrica no desde la
cuestión del crecimiento económico y de
las relaciones comerciales que eso sería
un poco la perspectiva y el plan que ha
tenido china con el continente africano
lo que quiere hacer europa es contribuir
a la paz la seguridad la buena
gobernanza en los países africanos eso
entonces sí mostraría un poco más de
entendimiento por parte de europa en
este 2022 de la agenda y las necesidades
que está teniendo el continente africano
más allá del desarrollo en
infraestructura más allá del desarrollo
económico que piensa usted
lo vuelvo a decir incluso en esta cumbre
que vuelvo a decir volvemos a repetir lo
que pasó en la cumbre de abiyán estamos
hablando de prosperidad seguridad
movilidad pero esas esos tres ejes que
estamos hablando desde qué perspectivas
está se está planteando y la y la
perspectiva desde la que se está
planteando generalmente es desde la
perspectiva europea europa está
dispuesta a hacer concesiones en su
relación con áfrica y en esas propuestas
que incluso se están haciendo en esta
cumbre que están teniendo lugar ahora
europa está dispuesta a ser concesiones
es decir en materia de inmigración
cuando áfrica está diciendo queremos
oportunidades para poder viajar para
poder ya sea por por viajes de turismo
estudios etcétera para nuestros
ciudadanos mientras europa en su agenda
lo que quiere es un blindaje de
fronteras ese es un ejemplo que puedo
si incluso en materia de seguridad
en el sahel el planteamiento muchas
veces
y africana no es la que se está teniendo
en cuenta desde las cancillerías
europeas claro david su opinión sobre
este tema sobre esta aproximación de la
unión europea
paz seguridad buena gobernanza pero
están estos reclamos la presencia en el
sahel la ayuda para blindarse entonces
el continente europeo ante el problema
de la migración a través de el
mediterráneo un poco recogiendo algunas
de las palabras de sanz y cuál es su
opinión
sí yo creo que la unión europea lo que
eres también diferenciarse un poco de
china y sacar a ciertas cosas que no
puede ofrecer china o que no ofrece
china saben que a la hora de hacer
préstamos o inversiones de
infraestructura es muy difícil competir
con el músculo financiero el chino pero
sí que quiere distanciarse en temas de
mencionabas de buena gobernanza de
seguridad y apoyo contra el terrorismo y
6 está por ejemplo también de apoyo a
las energías verdes pero bueno todo eso
también lleva contradicciones por lo que
de alguna manera se ha hecho hasta ahora
y efectivamente a ver si esta cumbre de
una vez ayuda a esa gente africana se
escucha más y el error de alguna manera
o por el fracaso de deseamos la
operación marca francesa y alguna manera
una presencia europea en en mali ciertas
partes del satélite ayude a que haya más
presencia de tropas africanas y más
propuestas nacidas desde los países
africanos para que eso ocurra está listo
por ejemplo en el norte de tanzania que
en la provincia de cabo delgado hay una
insurgente lista lista también me
demandará a tropas europeas de alguna
manera implementar una visión europea
el liderazgo a la armonía de áfrica
austral y a tropas ugandesas para
intentar compartir esta es esta una
manera más fantástica no no sé si de
alguna manera después salen hasta qué
punto esta europa dispuesta a ceder o no
se la iniciativa es la gran david
continuó con usted aquí hay reclamos de
parte y parte tanto desde bruselas como
desde addis abeba en nombre de estos 55
estados africanos
quiero hacer balance de las partes
comienzo con david haciendo el balance y
los reclamos que hace bruselas a áfrica
precisamente siempre han visto al
continente europeo como una
una garantía de
recibir todo tipo de contribuciones a
nivel económico
ayuda financiera ayuda militar pero que
la reclama bruselas a áfrica para que
esta relación no despegue para que esta
relación siempre sea con tantos y tantas
complicaciones en el camino
bueno europa siempre tenido
evidentemente la ración muy muy muy
cercana a 200 canales sí que es verdad
que yo creo que de alguna manera el
tener menos es por vídeos canciones por
un lado para y luego venir atada más
dentro de las organizaciones
internacionales a cumplir con ciertas
indicaciones democráticas democráticas
occidentales diferentemente es una
democracia liberal occidental que de
alguna manera no casan con con lo que
ocurre en un continente no ayudado pero
por otro lado europa y eeuu bill antes
de estas ayudas de esa visión de
cooperación y quiere pero una razón
según dicen más de tú a tú más directa
más de inversiones mutuas pero están muy
lejos y un ejemplo de por ejemplo el
tratado de libre comercio
que nació en 2021 para que simplemente
cápita de lo que quieres
industrializarse para que ello ocurra
hay muchas cuestiones con impactos con
europa que deberían de ser con ejemplo
gana en costa de marfil es exportan por
10 por ciento de tarifas
el cacao en grano pero ya no pasa na
polvo 7% si ya lo pasan a lo que sería
una tableta de chocolate es un 15 por
ciento de tarifa por lo tanto los
generosos incentivos para que áfrica
prosperen si haciendo está lista para
generar esa competencia turín masa
llegamos a simetría que está basada en
europa una manera de ayudando así acá
debe cambiar mucho pero está claro ahora
hagamos la otra cara de la moneda sanz y
ya ha mencionado algunos de los reclamos
que hay desde el lado africano sobre
esta relación histórica con el
continente europeo pero tal vez puede
ser que no sé qué piense usted sunny que
una de las de las equivocaciones de
europa es entender a áfrica como un
continente completamente homogéneo
cuando no lo es a nivel económico hay
países con mucho potencial económico
países muy ricos en petróleo como sudán
como nigeria pero otros países con
graves problemas económicos burkina faso
malí problemas de seguridad desarrollo
tecnológico completamente es igual
o ruanda y sudáfrica con una tecnología
un poco más avanzada con respecto a
otros en fin no es un continente
homogéneo y tampoco es culturalmente
homogéneo más de 2.000 lenguas se hablan
allí en los diferentes países la lectura
ha sido abordarlos por igual cuando
debería ser
en diferentes niveles o escalas como lo
entiende usted
si generalmente cuando se habla de
áfrica no es solo
en términos políticos o diplomáticos
sino también
incluso en las academias occidentales
que es donde la mayoría de los
dirigentes de la unión europea en este
caso han hecho sus estudios y se han
formado no entonces esa es la realidad
que vemos hoy por ejemplo por ejemplo
cuando el presidente macro estaba
haciendo el anuncio de la retirada de
deba llevar jan de la operación bajan en
mali más de una ocasión ha hablado de
áfrica como un conjunto cuando estamos
hablando en este caso pues del sahel y
de algunos países en concreto con el que
tiene así eso es esos acuerdos no y eso
también determina muchas veces la
ambigüedad con la que los los países
occidentales en este caso la unión
europea también trata a ciertos países
africanos muchas veces hablan de la
gobernanza hablan de la democracia que
se quieren implementar dentro del
continente africano y lo que los
africanos generalmente dice y que no se
les oye nadie es que en vez de
democratizar áfrica hay que áfrica niza
la democracia y lo vemos con esa
ambigüedad también en las relaciones que
como nos explicamos que en la cumbre en
esta cumbre seguramente se va a evitar
hablar de gobernanza porque ya no no
pueden legitimar hablar de gobernanza
cuando invita a dirigentes como el
dirige el hijo de idriss deby el actual
presidente de chad que a su militar ya
está también en el poder lo que se le
reprocha amalio a burkina faso y guinea
conakry es lo que se está aceptando con
la llegada en este caso del presidente
del hijo del presidente débil en esta
cumbre y luego como se puede legitimar
hablar de gobernanza cuando se está
acogiendo en esta cumbre al presidente
controvertido también de ruanda en este
caso no antes era muy fácil hablar de
gobernanza porque se podía hablar y
señalar a robert mugabe por ejemplo o
gadafi que ahora que ya no están y yo
estoy seguro que se va aa
y hablar de este tema de gobernanza por
eso digo que hay que ir con
particularidades el continente africano
es un continente muy complejo y lo saben
perfectamente incluso en esta relación
que quiere tener europa y áfrica
evidentemente tiene que ser una relación
de igual pero entendiendo también la
fragilidad del continente africano
'david la unión europea está compuesto
como lo decía al inicio del programa por
27 estados algunos de estos estados como
por ejemplo francia portugal españa e
incluso italia tienen un pasado
histórico muy cercano a áfrica pero hay
otros países de la unión europea que no
tienen ningún tipo de relación con este
continente es difícil para la unión
europea a ser consenso en cuanto a la
estrategia para abordar las relaciones
de estos con estos países africanos
porque no sé por ejemplo un gobierno
como estonia letonia y rumanía no le
interesa en lo más absoluto tener algún
tipo de relacionamiento
a profundidad como si le interesa
francia a españa o portugal que tienen
territorios en donde fueron la colonia
durante varios siglos
si totalmente es decir macro por ejemplo
es ahora mismo diría la cabeza más
visible
dentro de la unión europea para espacios
económicas antes es decir si eso es algo
positivo pero bueno sí que lo es y
evidentemente españa está también ahí
está portugal pero igual que la unión
europea tiene problemas internos se
sirve el bloque del este por decirlo así
las antiguas
en países soviéticos sí que tienen menos
relación evidentemente y menos interés
en unas relaciones con el continente
africano por ejemplo lo que hablábamos
del pacto global de estos 50.000
millones de euros polonia ya ha
mencionado que cuidado lo que ellos no
están muy dispuestos a participar es
hondo para el continente africano luego
también hemos visto por ejemplo que
makro ha intentado liberar que se
redirijan los derechos especiales de
giro es un mecanismo de financiación del
fondo monetario internacional de los
países europeos a países africanos para
ayudar a recuperar en una pandemia
españa ha dicho si portugal ha dicho si
italia dichos y franceses sí y ya está
14 de 27 entonces sí que es verdad que
estáis de más conexiones y además tres
en alguna manera mantener sus conexiones
económicas e históricas que tienen el
resto de países sobre todo el bloque del
este digamos son más ambiguos claro
hablemos de los pasos inmediatos que hay
dentro de los acuerdos y bueno también
dependemos de lo que arroje de
conclusiones esta cumbre africana pero
lo mencionábamos el global gateway
estima entregar una iniciativa de
inversiones 150.000 millones de euros
que dará la unión europea al continente
africano ese sería un primer paso desde
bruselas y también está el tema de las
vacunas que ya generó hay ciertas
discrepancias entre ambas partes está
este monto que se destinará a que se va
a
y entregar con qué fin y tomemos en
cuenta que también hay unas hay unos
puntos complejos con algunos países como
malí como burkina faso que acaban de
sufrir golpes de estado que los
gobiernos europeos todavía están un poco
reticentes a
formalizar hay relaciones están llamando
a elecciones también en guinea hubo un
intento de golpe de estado también en
guinea bisseau esta primera partida de
dinero entonces como se va a distribuir
y qué destino tendrá sanz
esto es su parte también de grandes
anuncios que hacen en la unión europea
y como que se retroalimentan yo recuerdo
después de la cumbre que hubo en malta
en el 2000 2015 también se aprobó un
fondo fiduciario para áfrica que
básicamente a lo que se limitó era para
impedir la llegada la llegada de los
inmigrantes hacia asia europa no
entonces vamos a ver evidentemente cómo
se va a distribuir esto lo que lo que
vienen lo que vienen diciendo y también
en qué condiciones porque de eso se
trata porque muchas veces eso
esas esas cantidades de dineros que se
anuncian de esa manera van también
sujetos a unas condiciones que
generalmente históricamente se ha visto
que no es viable que se respete porque
si el que da es el que pone la regla
generalmente se olvida en este caso de
la agenda de los países africanos que es
lo que yo decía antes claro en cualquier
caso a lo que se tiene que destinar esto
si esto no respeta de los países
africanos volveremos a lo mismo dentro
de tres años porque esas cumbres
normalmente están pensadas que van a
tener lugar cada tres años y ya llevamos
cinco años porque desde la última en el
2017 en abiyán que también hubo grandes
declaraciones y la cosa no ha avanzado
en clarés llc el escepticismo en el
continente africano también es
justificado en este caso yo digo que en
cualquier caso a lo que se tiene que
destinar tiene que tener en cuenta la
agenda del continente africano porque
sino como dice encontrar estar a china
ya rusia va a ser muy complicado 'david
150.000 millones de euros han enviado
400 millones de dosis de vacunas contra
el cob y 19 desde el continente europeo
europa es el principal exportador de
vacunas en el mundo pero se le adelantó
china con esto de la diplomacia de las
vacunas entregando también
millones de dosis de las vacunas chinas
en el continente africano cuál es la
prioridad entonces estas inversiones
acercarse por el lado de las vacunas
como cree usted que puede ser esa
aproximación
bueno en el tema del pacto global de
europa mencionado actualmente la energía
menciona transporte mencionan creación
de empleos pero no especifica pues ahí
de alguna manera aún no sabemos
exactamente a qué se dedicarán así que
se sabe que está a un máximo de 20 mil
millones cada año de ahí seis mil
millones son fondos comunitarios
ciudadanía europea y el resto dinero o
bien de los países miembros y de ahí las
discrepancias que no se crean eso va a
llegar a sus 150 20 millones porque ese
países como polonia te están diciendo
que no no vas a llegar y luego de entes
privados y en el tema de las vacunas
más que donar vacunas aplicadores
producir leche entonces esa es la clave
a partir de ahora de alguna manera de
ahí ponemos a través de un poco a la
libres en de los patentes en las que se
basa este estado vance que se hicieron y
ahora fue aplicada creada la primera
final por una virus esa matriz llena y
en esta cumbre de alguna manera de que
hablar máster el donante yo te doy a ti
te dejo de alguna manera mi remanente
que además ha creado problemas porque
muchas veces se enviaban algunas a un
par de semanas de caducar por lo tanto
era imposible la administración de la
relación los países africanos tenían que
tirar nuestra basura quedaba muy mal se
habla más de producción de alguna manera
poner los mecanismos para clasificar
importar a día de hoy en hoy por ciento
las vacunas las produzca dentro
sanz y david ya vamos llegando a la
recta final del programa quiero cerrar
con el tema de seguridad y por los
anuncios recientemente hechos por parte
de francia retirar a las tropas
francesas y de sus aliados de malí donde
estaban allí llevando a cabo operaciones
para contrarrestar la presencia de los
yihadistas pero de las apuestas dentro
de esta cumbre es reforzar la seguridad
no es esto un poco contradictorio david
ver que la apuesta más la seguridad pero
están retirando las tropas y se quejan
de la presencia de los mercenarios rusos
de conocidos como wagner que algunos
analistas dicen que tiene una estrecha
relación con el kremlin eso no es
cederle terreno a los rusos como ya lo
hicieron en la república centroafricana
por ejemplo
pues sí de alguna manera puede parecer
contradictorio también hay que entender
todo esto en una misión de alguna manera
porque dices a mí europa piensa en
intereses y hasta cierto punto más
grande bien es aspirar estas elecciones
para que te viene tal vez hay un
sentimiento francés mayor en asia
occidental
antes de salir peor salgo a tiempo ya
mal quedó mal y de alguna manera me que
es el de rusia pero lo que intenta a
partir de ahora también europa es bien
lo que ellos han tenido éxito de una
manera es reír sus puertos poner esa eso
de alguna manera responsabilidad en los
distintos locales que apoyar más local
entonces sí evidentemente es una cumbre
vital para ver de alguna manera cómo
salimos adelante no porque no puede
retirarse
quizá ni su opinión sobre este tema de
seguridad se van las tropas francesas de
malí
existe la posibilidad de que lleguen
tropas de los mercenarios wagner de
rusia ya hay presencia de ellos en
varios países africanos
está áfrica preparada para
y mantener su seguridad en sus propias
manos siendo la seguridad un tema
importante para esta cumbre
claro es que el tema de la seguridad
también es un tema en el que se ha
utilizado digamos para mantener esa
ep esa dependencia desde el continente
africano y en este caso de los países
del sahel esa dependencia a las fuerzas
que vienen de fuera
yo digo siempre que en esto también hay
que escuchar a la opinión pública
africana hay que escuchar a los
dirigentes africanos que es lo que dicen
los dirigentes africanos y es realmente
con lo que se tiene que se tiene que
trabajar
cuando los dirigentes de malí decidieron
mantener abrir un diálogo con una parte
de
esos aristas
claramente el elíseo lo que lo que hizo
fue oponerse a eso y entonces yo creo
que la solución a esa no no puede ser
una solución militar que es lo que se ha
venido haciendo durante mucho tiempo hay
muchas cuestiones que se tienen que
tener en cuenta hay
evidentemente y no se ha tenido cuenta
el tema por ejemplo los temas sociales
de los temas socioeconómicos de la
población la población ha sido siempre
apartada de las decisiones que se ha ido
tomando ahí y la población es la que ha
tomado la calle y en varios países
africanos lo estamos viendo en abril lo
estaba diciendo hace un rato no es un
sentimiento antifrancés es un
sentimiento anti política francesa que
es diferente que hay que matizar en este
sentido no eso se está viendo cuando yo
escuché he escuchado hoy al presidente
macro no decir que la población está
siendo manipulada eso es infantilizar
también a la población de estos países
porque no podemos decir que la cantidad
de gente que ha salido en la calle en
mali si siendo que ya no no que basta ya
no podemos decir que esa población está
siendo manipulada simplemente así porque
hay muchas cuestiones de fondo que
también francia y la unión europea en
este caso y janine que tener en cuenta
me queda un minuto para las conclusiones
del programa por favor muy puntual para
el cierre
david que va a dejar entonces esta
cumbre en tres años estaremos haciendo
el mismo balance que no se avanzó en lo
más mínimo en las diferentes tareas que
se deja de parte y parte y que está en
el mismo punto de inicio o que va a
haber grandes avances y que europa
recuperará un poco el espacio perdido en
áfrica
yo creo que en este caso estaremos en
los grises así que vamos a ver
conclusiones en material sanitario y yo
creo que materia de pandemia de alguna
manera es donde europa más quiere dar un
avance y creo que al menos el punto de
vista long europea pero no esté
activamente por favor
sanz y muy puntual para el cierre
yo creo que más que más que decir que
europa tiene que recuperar el terreno
perdido creo que también la visión hay
que mirar qué es lo que necesita el
continente de áfrica ción en estas
relaciones y es la única manera
evidentemente para tengo que dejar por
ahí porque se me acaba el tiempo debo
dar paso al informativo muchas gracias a
ustedes por haber estado con nosotros
aquí en el debate de france 24 sigan
dejando sus preguntas y comentarios en
las redes sociales sigan con france24
[Música]